[موسيقى]
رسميا يترشح المغرب مع اسبانيا والبرتغال
لاستضافه كاس العالم عام 2030
الاعلان جاء اثناء تكريم للملك محمد
السادس بجائزه الانجاز المميز من قبل رئيس
الاتحاد الافريقي لكره القدم
اعلنوا امام جمعكم هذا ان المملكه
المغربيه قد قررت بمعيه اسبانيا والبرتغال
تقديم ترشيح مشترك لتنظيم كاس العالم لسنه
اغرب التقدم بملف لتنظيم كاس العالم عام
2010 لكنه خسر فرصه لاستضافه لصالح جنوب
افريقيا حقق المنتخب المغربي انجازا كبيرا
في نهائيات كاس العالم لعام الماضي فقد
اصبح اول منتخب افريقي يصل الى قبل
النهائي واليوم يتطلع الى الافضل
ان شاء الله ان شاء الله نجيبوا كاس
العالم في المغرب
ونفرحو الشعب ديالنا
تقدمت ايضا كل من الارجنتين وباراغواي
وتشيلي واوروغواي بملف مشترك نجاح هذا
الملف يعني عوده شرف تنظيم هذا الحدث
الرياضي العالمي الى اوروغواي بعد مئه عام
على استضافتها اول نهائيات لكاس العالم